hello folks how you all doing
now i normally do this thing i i teach
speaker workshops and i say to people
get there like 20 minutes early get
everything plugged in and everything and
of course uh we just decided we were
going to drop the sessions that got
cancelled yesterday got slotted into
lunch so we've just done like a 90
second turnaround it's like changing the
tires on a formula one car only with
more laptops and stuff so uh yeah but
the good thing is this is talk about
failure so if anything goes wrong i'm
just going to pretend that it was part
of the script so
and yes this is a failure is always an
option so uh those who don't know me
this is me dylan beatty i run a company
called versatile that i started in
january 2020 so i could do lots of
traveling and go around the world and
talk to people and worst business plan
ever
but it's all right it's slowly kind of
kicking into gear i'm a microsoft mvp i
uh occasionally still organize a meeting
of the london.net user group we're
trying to get that back up and running
after a hiatus of a couple years and uh
i once invented a programming language
in a bar as a joke that has become a
programming language with three
different implementations and now i have
to project manage the joke because
that's what open source does
but if any of you ever wanted to be a
rockstar developer so you can go and
apply for all those jobs on linkedin go
to code with rockstar.com type in a
program the more it looks like an 80s
heavy metal song the better that's the
whole idea and if it compiles then you
are a rockstar programmer and you can go
and get a all those sweet jobs on
linkedin now
the title for this talk is uh sort of
loosely paraphrased
from a line in this movie apollo 13
there's a point about an hour into that
film where uh this guy so this is the
actor ed harris playing um gene krantz
who was the mission director on the real
apollo 13 and it comes out with this
great line failure is not an option
now
gene krantz didn't say that well
actually he did say it but he didn't say
it in 1972 when apollo 13 was happening
this is gene krantz
and he said that in an interview with
the people who wrote the screenplay for
the movie
they were talking to you know all the
people who had been involved in the real
life mission apollo 13 and uh one point
apparently they're saying you know what
were you thinking when you started
getting all this telemetry data and
crown says in this interview you know we
were
we realized that you know we had to
bring the people home that failure was
not an option and apparently they looked
at each other went that's it that's the
tagline for the movie
and then he borrowed his own line back
from them and that became the title of
his autobiography
which has a lot of really cool
information about you know working on
apollo and apollo 13 particularly but
by this point by the point in the in the
movie and the story that it's based on
when he says failure is not an option uh
they have already had one crew member
have to be pulled out and replaced
because he was suspected of having
measles uh they've had a main engine
shut down the apollo uh launched on a
vehicle called the saturn v it's called
the saturn v because it's got five
engines a couple of seconds after launch
one of them just stops working and we're
talking a big rocket engine but they're
like yeah it's fine just switch over
we'll burn the other for a little bit
longer and by this point in the apollo
program you know apollo 13 was the the
13th mission to carry that designation
they had had all sorts of failures from
you know trivial mechanical component
failures to uh fire on the launch pad
which actually killed the three
astronauts on uh on apollo 1. so
to understand
what he means by failure is not an
option you have to understand the
context you have to understand you know
what is the definition of success
that is relevant at this point in that
narrative now the saturn launch vehicle
it had
99.9 reliability that's what they were
shooting for
it had six million components and moving
parts so a successful mission was one
where only six thousand things went
wrong that was their definition of a
successful launch for that and uh one of
the engineers who worked on the apollo
system was was this lady margaret
hamilton
she was the first person to use the
phrase software engineering and she was
a huge advocate she led the team that
built the built the guidance software
that took apollo to the moon and you
know she has this quote she says you
begin to think in terms of modeling all
of these things as one system part of it
is realized as software part is realized
as people where part of it is realized
as hardware and that was the principle
behind systems thinking you know we need
to look at not a question of did this
component succeed or fail you need to
keep stepping back and you're like well
what does success look like in that what
does that component mean in terms of the
assembly that it's applied what does
that assembly mean in terms of the
machine what does the machine mean in
terms of the mission what does the
mission mean in terms of the goal you
know probably the the best user story of
all time land
a man on the moon and return him safely
to the earth you know that's a hell of a
definition of done and doesn't say
anything about how they are going to
accomplish it
and by apollo 13
had kind of done that you know john f
kennedy stood up in 1962 rice university
and he laid out this is what we are
doing this is what success looks like
people on the moon bring them safely
back to earth
when
was that marked as done when was the you
know mission accomplished well maybe it
was july the 20th when they set foot on
the moon or maybe it was july the 24th
when they got back to earth but then
they were in quarantine for a month in
case they brought back any moon bugs so
maybe it was august 18th when it's like
okay we are now satisfied we sent them
there we got them back
and we're pretty sure that they're safe
you know these are the definitions of
success that you need to kind of dig
into a little bit and uh you know this
was the the headline this is the point
when the world says yes we did that july
20th 1969. um incidentally there's a
game where how much can you change
history using the smallest amendment to
a newspaper headline which has always
made me wonder if they'd accidentally
put an extra comma in that and they'd be
like wow there are plants on the moon
and they brought some back but uh
now the mission after apollo 11
apollo 12 it became the second
successful mission to land on the moon
but it very nearly didn't apollo 12 was
struck by lightning twice during takeoff
now i want you to just imagine that
you're kind of strapped into this this
capsule you and your the other two crew
members in a thing smaller than a
compact car you know you're kind of
strapped in you've got your space
helmets on everything
you are on six million litres of highly
explosive rocket fuel and suddenly there
is a catastrophic bang sound like an
explosion and all the lights go out and
you're thinking
hmm what do we do now
and you know what they did
this guy
uh this was uh john aaron and john aaron
is looking at all these things on his
dashboard he's one of the people who's
working mission control out there and
he's like
everything has failed but the spacecraft
still appears to be going up
maybe the thing that has blown is the
thing that tells us whether it's working
or not thing called the signal
conditioning equipment one of the
circuits on there and they had a
procedure you know you've got a rocket
six million liters of fuel on board
taking off into space you get struck by
lightning twice and nasa are like all
right well we didn't simulate exactly
this but we've simulated power failures
before we've simulated system failures
before and if you go back to this famous
photograph of margaret hamilton the
console that is above her head there is
the main instrument console on the
apollo capsule and it includes this
little thing down in the corner this is
the signal conditioning equipment and it
has two power supplies it has normal and
it has auxiliary
failure was clearly an option because
they put a switch on the dashboard that
you could flick if you realized that
there was no power going to the the
signal conditioning equipment and uh if
that hadn't worked they had a whole
bunch of other options up to and
including a thing called the apollo
launch escape system which was basically
an ejector seat could fire the astronaut
capsule off the top of the rocket
ideally just before it exploded and that
would then parachute back to earth now
this thing was never used you know the
saturn v and apollo it has the
remarkable pedigree it's one of the few
rockets in history that never blew up
and uh
the full quote that uh gene krantz is
referencing at that point in the movie
was this we've never lost an american in
space we are sure as hell not gonna lose
one on my watch
failure is not an option so at this
point this context
failure means losing an astronaut in
space that is the definition of success
that they have reframed and decided this
is what we are optimizing for now this
is what we are going to try and
accomplish
now apollo 12 went to the moon apollo 13
got headlines because a lot of stuff
went wrong but they did uh don't spoil
the end of the movie or anything but
they get them back to earth safely at
the end of it and they flew a bunch more
apollo missions but everyone was kind of
getting a bit bored because i apollo 12
13. um apollo 14 the most interesting
thing that happened was uh pete conrad
took up a golf club and he hit a golf
ball on the moon apollo 15 they sent up
the little moon buggy so they could
drive around um apollo 17 was the last
one the only one that ever carried an
actual scientist as opposed to just uh
astronauts and pilots
and then that was it they're like yeah
we're not going to do any more of these
but
they had something else in the works
they had the
the space transportation system thing
that everyone knows as the space shuttle
uh now the space shuttle was never
actually a thing it was a nickname this
the space transportation system
consisted of the orbiter
the external fuel tank massive orange
thing underneath with all the fuel on
board and these two solid rocket
boosters one on either side of it and uh
the space transportation system the
space shuttle the first shuttle flight
was in 1981 and it incorporated an awful
lot of ideas from apollo lots of
technology got reused lots of systems
lots of components but it also
incorporated loads of new stuff stuff
that nasa had never flown before
including something called a fly-by-wire
system
now
fly-by-wire is uh historically aircraft
spacecraft there would be mechanical
connections between the things that the
pilot moved and the control surfaces and
valves that made the aircraft or the
spacecraft maneuver fly by wire you push
a button or move a lever it tells the
computer what you did and the computer
works out what to do with the aircraft
or spacecraft to make it reflect that
input and uh the shuttle had a
fly-by-wire system on board and uh the
guidance computer system that it used
basically once it's in space it can kind
of stay there while you figure stuff out
but during launch and during landing
those are the critical times when they
couldn't afford
anything to go wrong now
to understand how they approach this
we got to think a little bit about how
software fails how systems fail um there
are three different failure modes that
we kind of get you imagine you open up
your laptop you go to a website and
you get this
you just get straight away error message
that didn't work something is wrong here
is the error it's your problem now or
you get this
and you wait
and you wait and uh eventually something
is going to give up you are going to
lose patience your network connection is
going to say time out the uh you know
infrastructure is going to go there is
nothing on the other end of this
or
eventually you give up but the third
failure mode
is you get something that looks right
but it's not right
you get results which are plausible but
are incorrect
so
in this scenario you know maybe you
don't notice or maybe you're like
spongebob invades lux no hang on so you
need to check it against another
authority so you get this on your laptop
you're like it's a bit weird and uh you
go you get your phone out you look on
that you're like all right well
according to my phone uh biden signed
off a tax deal and uh
let me check my tablet all right okay so
clearly the news is actually the tax
deal thing and there's something wrong
with my laptop i can't trust it i've got
a virus or someone is intercepting my
network traffic i can no longer rely on
that system but maybe you get spongebob
invades luxembourg you get your phone
out and it says mexico just won
eurovision so you check your ipad and it
says nasa's found brexit opportunities
on mars
and you're like this is a you know a
systemic failure all of these devices
are breaking down and so you fail over
to a completely different system you go
to a store you buy a newspaper and
you're like right give me news that
hasn't been filtered through whoever is
interfering with my internet
so these are the failure modes that we
need to anticipate now
the space shuttle flew with five of
these this is an ipm ibm ap101 it's
basically a mainframe in a box
five of these on board the space shuttle
and the way that they were configured
the way that they were installed was
really interesting four of them
ran identical copies of the same
software
so exactly the same code same routines
with the same system clock
and the same inputs
so all four of them are taking telemetry
from the same sensors at the same time
with the same cpu cycle and most of the
time they agree the idea is that under
normal operation these will always give
you the same output from the same input
at the same time and this means
everything is fine this means everything
is working if one of them
suddenly gives you something different
you're like okay
that is overwhelmingly likely to be a
failure of that particular system
something in that computer has gone
wrong
we should stop listening to it that
leaves you with three now three is good
enough
that you can still get a majority at
this point you're like okay another
one's gone wrong
but if you get to here
you don't know which one of these is
correct now this is what is known as an
abort condition because uh the space
shuttle they didn't want to lose it in
space because the computers couldn't
bring it back to earth so if you got
into this scenario that was you stop
what you're doing and you come home
immediately actually you had to come
home stop doing what you're doing to
come home immediately if you lost any
one computer because then if you lost
another one on the way home you'd be
down to two and then you wouldn't know
what you were doing if those two started
disagreeing so there are safeguards on
top of safeguards on top of safeguards
but
if these four all suddenly started
giving contradictory gibberish
at that point all of the flight
telemetry would switch over to the fifth
computer because their analysis there
are a lot of people at nasa working on
statistics and probabilities uh you know
what is the likelihood that if this
thing goes wrong that thing's also going
to go wrong and uh this computer was
running a completely different set of
software written by a different supplier
based on the same specification
and their hypothesis was that there
might be a bug in system a of running on
all those four there might be a bug in
system b but that probably wasn't the
same bug in the same place in the same
code neither of these systems was going
to be 100 reliable
but if one of them had a problem here
the other one probably didn't have a
problem in the same place so if all four
of them went haywire you could fail up
to the fifth one and that was enough to
bring the orbiter home now the first
couple of shuttle missions
they actually flew with a sixth they had
a spare one on board that wasn't loaded
with anything it was just a you know
blank computer the idea being that if
they needed to they could plug this
thing in and then go through the
procedure to copy all the flight
telemetry data across to it and they
flew with this one for about five
missions and then
congress and you know funding and nasa
management were like
it costs a lot of money to send a spare
computer into space that we don't use
we could fly cargo with that and you
know claw back some of the massive
amount of money that's being poured into
the shuttle program
and so they stopped flying it
now
as it turns out the space shuttle
guidance computer was flawless it never
had a problem it flew perfectly for the
entire lifetime of the the space
transportation system program um but as
i'm sure you're all aware there were
other factors in the shuttle uh program
which had the same kind of attitude to
risk this thing hasn't gone wrong maybe
we don't need to worry about it anymore
which would go on and have tragic
consequences
now
human beings suck at risk
how many of you are anyone in here
afraid of flying
yeah anyone here frightened of taxis
no statistically you are far more likely
to get into an accident in a car than
you are on an airplane you know if you
spend the same number of hours every
year flying as you do driving the odds
are way higher that you'll be in a car
accident than that you'll be in a plane
accident but that's not how our brains
work because we ride in cars every day
because cars are safe right and you know
i know people who have been in serious
car accidents and they have a completely
different attitude to riding in cabs and
you know that kind of thing but you know
most people they get on the ground after
a flight and if they're a nervous flyer
they'll be like ah
i'm down i survived and then they'll get
a taxi from the airport without even
thinking about it that is the high risk
part of the journey is the trip to and
from the airport not the bit where
you're up in the sky
but
we think about planes and because most
of us have never been in a plane crash
our perception of that is based on media
and it's based on stories and hollywood
and television and news headlines but
our perception of riding in cars is
we've spent hundreds of hours writing in
cars and nothing really happened and so
we don't really appreciate the amount of
risk that's involved now
you think about installing a new piece
of software you know upgrading something
updating something i've done this dozens
of times over the course of my career
and uh what generally happens is you
think okay we need to migrate all of our
customer data from the the old database
onto the new crm platform and so you'll
rehearse it you'll figure out okay what
do we need to migrate when can we do
this what are the dependent systems
what might go wrong
and you know you you approach this stuff
well and you have the budget and the
time to do a good job on it you will
talk to all the people who work on those
systems and you'll be like can you just
keep an eye out for this thing or this
thing like these are some things we are
worried might not work and then you roll
out the new system
and
you keep an eye on it and probably as a
couple of things go wrong on the first
day and the second day you know but
after a while it kind of settles down
now there is a thing called a bathtub
curve it's a graph of
failures of a system versus time and
most systems do this
when they are new they are full of stuff
that either just wasn't built right or
hasn't kind of been yet didn't
anticipate the load you didn't
anticipate the traffic volume so you
have to jump in and fix a bunch of stuff
there then everything just kind of
rattles along for the lifespan of that
system or that product and then you get
to the end of it and the number of
failures starts going up again
and uh the reason the failures go up at
the end is because when you get to a
certain number of failures you decide
that's it and that that is the end of
the life of the system it's now too
unreliable you're not going to use it
anymore but
hiding behind the bathtub these
are the early life cycle defects these
are like i said the things that the bugs
the things you didn't get right the
things you missed in your planning and
your provisioning
these are the random defects which just
kind of rattle along in any system for
as long as it's running and these are
the end of life defects which uh in
mechanical systems this is when parts
start to wear out um in software this is
where you can't be bothered to install
windows updates anymore or you know
these kinds of things because you know
software doesn't wear out but you do
reach a point where you're like i can't
update this anymore because i this
thing's incompatible with that thing and
that thing can't be upgraded so we do
still have to anticipate this notion of
an engineered lifespan and really what
these three things mean is it's a new
system stay alert everybody be vigilant
and then you've got the relax
everything's fine and then you've got
the
yeah bugs but it doesn't matter we're
getting the new system put in anytime
soon and so people develop a kind of
laissez-faire attitude to it now
the problem here
is that the random defects
can often be dismissed as early life
cycle defects you think okay the number
of bugs for the sort of first iterations
of a system it decreases rapidly and we
naturally think that it's going to tend
towards zero
but it doesn't and so we can get defects
in a system that are hiding there that
because they don't blow up early on
we think this is not a problem we need
to worry about
the space shuttle had uh protocols for
everything it had a the spare computer
they carried on board it had all kinds
of you know mission procedures and
parameters and guidelines for how you
had to amend or cut short the mission
under certain circumstances
but it was also under a huge amount of
pressure to keep flying missions you
know the united states and congress they
put a huge amount of money and
investment into this thing and they
wanted it flying all the time every time
that they cut short or they delayed a
launch
people had to go to meetings and answer
questions and so the pressure was always
on are we being too careful the protocol
says we have to cancel now
but last time we were right on the
threshold and we went for it and it was
fine maybe the protocols are being too
stringent now
there was a thing called the space
shuttle weather launch criteria um the
shuttle couldn't launch if it was
raining
it couldn't launch if the wind was above
a certain speed it couldn't launch if
the temperature was above a certain
level but there was no minimum
temperature in the launch criteria
because it's florida you know everyone
thinks it's warm and sunny you don't
worry about this kind of stuff
now
in january 1984
they launched the shuttle when it was 13
degrees celsius outside
it went okay in uh january 85 they
launched when it was 10 degrees outside
and one of the contractors a company
called morton thiacol they said
we don't think this is a good idea
and nasa said are you telling us that
you are going to accept responsibility
for scrubbing the launch and they went
no
we just think it's not a good idea
and this happened a couple of times and
every time you know it went into the
record as you know morton thiakol who
supplied the solid rocket boosters they
have advised that this could be risky so
we flew anyway and nothing happened
until
space shuttle challenger exploded
73 seconds after launch the crew on
board were all killed the temperature
that day was three degrees celsius
now the investigatory board they looked
into this and they determined that what
had caused the explosion was a rubber
seal around one of those solid rocket
boosters that wasn't resealing properly
because it got cold and it got brittle
and uh the person who actually
identified it was uh this guy is richard
feynman he's a nobel prize was a nobel
prize winning physicist and uh they
asked him to work on the investigatory
board for the challenge of disaster and
then they said we don't like what you
said we're not going to publish it in
the main report they published it as an
appendix
and one of the things that he said in
that appendix is uh the certificate
certification criteria used in the
flight readiness reviews develops a
gradually decreasing strictness the
argument that the same risk was flown
before without failure is often accepted
as an argument for the safety of
accepting it again now imagine you go
out in your car one morning and you
can't get the seat belt to lock in
properly and you have to go like you've
got to be somewhere so you drive without
a seat belt and you're like all right
well i did that and i didn't die and so
the next day you do it again and you
booked the car into the shop to get it
fixed but it's going to be a couple of
weeks but by the time you take the car
and you've probably been driving around
without a seat belt for two weeks and
you're getting used to the idea
that it's fine
because you've taken the risk and
nothing bad has happened because human
beings are terrible at assessing risk
now nasa said that the probability of
failure of the space shuttle program was
one in one hundred thousand
feynman said the probability of the
space shuttle failing was one in one
hundred
the shuttle flew 135 missions and lost
two of them so he was pretty much bang
on the money on his estimate of the
reliability of that system now uh most
of us are not working on anything as you
know historically significant a space
flight we probably do have a few
enterprise developers in the room but
it's a different kind of enterprise
but uh
you know we have to anticipate the same
kind of you know what is the attitude to
risk what is the cost of mitigating that
risk what are the protocols and are we
getting sloppy with ourselves because
nothing has gone wrong yet now we live
in this glorious age of cloud computing
where it is relatively trivial to very
quickly provision almost any kind of
infrastructure that you need to cope
with unprecedented demand i've been
working in it since the days when you'd
look at your business plan for the year
be like we need to order some servers
now so that when they get here in six
weeks we have a month to get them set up
put in a rack switched on installed and
sitting there doing nothing for hundreds
of pounds a month
so that if the business is right about
this big spike in july we're gonna have
the capacity to deal with it we had like
a three to six month lead time on that
kind of capacity these days you can go
on to azure aws and go i need another
100 servers bang and uh you know it is
like
it's like having a company who will
deliver a fire extinguisher when you
smell smoke
so you don't need to worry about it
you're like do i smell burning yeah
quickly get me some fire extinguishers
they bring them in and you just need to
make sure that at the point when they
arrive you actually know how to use them
now
we can build the most
wonderfully high availability
distributed systems where we can
potentially lose an entire continent and
the system will just keep on trucking
because we've got reverse proxies going
into load balancers going into clustered
farms going to database servers with
active active replication the most
significant downtime incidents i've ever
seen on this kind of infrastructure
because somebody forgot about the single
point of failure which was the limit on
the mastercard
on the aws account that was running it
you know you've got all this lovely
stuff you're like well another one of
those another one of those and then it's
like
you have no money and we've suspended
all your services until you pay the bill
and you're like we've maxed out oops
that may have been a mistake
and at that point you know developers
are thinking well nobody told us we
needed a spare mastercard because it's
not systems thinking you're thinking
that money just comes out of the magical
money department and that's not
something that's going to affect your
availability
because hey we get another server get
another one of these but to deliver the
kind of availability we're talking about
we do need to anticipate failure modes
and we need to understand how our system
fits into the bigger system around it
and how that fits into society and how
that fits into the world at large and
these kind of headlines you know the
headlines about system failures
the thing they all have in common
is that people did not anticipate the
probability of failure they thought it
was not going to go wrong
in 1995 the uk post office limited uh
installed a new i.t system called
horizon it cost about a billion pounds
to put this thing together it was a
consultancy uh installed by fujitsu who
put it together installed it
took about four years to build so there
you go nice and agile there in 1999 they
rolled it out into 10 post office
branches they went
yeah this looks pretty good they rolled
it out across the entire post office
network and shortly after this it
started reporting discrepancies the
horizon i.t system said that money was
going missing the accounts did not add
up now
i want to imagine this is you
you have just installed a system you've
done a pilot on 10 offices it's had four
years being built by consultants and
then you are going to roll it out across
tens of thousands of branches it's
processing a few million transactions
per day
and employees are saying this is wrong
the computer is not adding it's not
giving us the right results what would
you do about it
because what the post office did about
it is they said we don't care you are
lying the computer is right give the
money back or you are going to jail
and the employees went
no and the post office went yes
give the money back if you don't give
the money back we are going to prosecute
you for stealing
and they did
and they uh
550 branch managers
were prosecuted as criminals
because of a computer system that didn't
work now they filed a class action
lawsuit a couple of years ago that was
eventually settled by the post office
limited for 58 million pounds now uh
this is uh paula vennels she's the chief
executive of post office or she was um
she's also i think a church of england
vicar which uh tells you everything you
need to know she's basically the person
who said uh oh no no it was fine the
employees must have been lying uh the
message that the board and i were given
from the highest levels was that white
like any i.t system horizon was not
perfect and had a limited life span it
was fundamentally sound
not perfect limited lifespan but you're
going to jail anyway
the judge who supervised on the
class-action lawsuit said you know the
post office's defense amounts in reality
to bear assertions and denials that
ignore what has actually occurred it's
the 21st century equivalent of
maintaining that the earth is flat
now this is
you know for a british high court judge
this is like seriously passionate
inflamed speech these people are very
very understated um in 2020 the
criminal review commission
basically reopened all of these
investigations and established that this
had been one of the biggest miscarriages
of justice in british legal history now
this is still going on there are still
investigations and you know
repercussions about this but what we
know is dozens of innocent people had
their lives ruined you know people
cashed in their life savings to pay this
back because they didn't want to get a
jail people mortgaged their houses a
couple of people you know died of uh
various you know illnesses and things
while these processes ongoing they never
got cleared you know they were they were
guilty until the day when they were no
longer around to to fight their corner
and i find that absolutely indefensible
now if you've ever worked help desk or
you've ever worked with human beings and
computers at the same time which let's
face it we have you will have had the
situation where the computer says one
thing and the human being says something
else and you'll have had the thing when
you're on help desk and someone phones
up and they're like uh i had files on my
desktop and now they're gone and you're
like well
you must have deleted them and the
person i didn't delete them and you're
like i know you deleted them
that's how files on desktops go missing
but you kind of go through the motions
you're like all right uh let me check
the backups and i'll call you back and
you don't check the backups you go and
get a cup of coffee and check reddit and
hacker news and then you phone again
really sorry i can't find any trace in
the backup can i come and have a look on
your look there they are you've dragged
them into the corner you know this kind
of thing but
if we were talking about tens of
thousands of pounds in money if we're
talking about potential criminal charges
i check you know i'd do the diligence i
think all of you probably would do the
same thing you'd be like well maybe the
human being is right for once and the
computer is wrong for once and at the
very least we're going to make sure
we've investigated all this before we
start giving you know handing out
criminal prosecutions to people
you know the consequences of refusing to
acknowledge the possibility of failure
they can be tragic they can be
frustrating they can be trivial uh
two-factor authentication is something
that is becoming increasingly common
security has been a big problem for a
lot of time you want to log into your
bank account they're like we'll send you
a text message um i have a friend who
lives in london who has no mobile phone
reception in her house for her to log
into just about anything important types
it in her laptop grabs her phone runs to
the end of the street and up a little
way so she can kind of hold her phone up
like this and hope she gets the code and
can then get back to her laptop and type
that in now the developers who built
that system they're like well it works
perfectly
100 of our text messages were sent and
you're like but did you think that maybe
there's people who don't have reception
at the exact place where they are trying
to sign into stuff and they don't
because that's not a software problem
that's a systemic problem you know it's
a a big scale problem no matter how
diligently you plan and anticipate these
systems if all you're looking at is
software real life
is going to throw stuff at you that you
could not possibly anticipate um this is
a recording of a uh the autopilot system
i'm not sure why we're getting one frame
per second off the video here
that's interesting
let me see why that's misbehaving
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
apparently the m1 macbook pro with the
new apple silicon will give you uh one
frame every two seconds
uh what we have here is a a video of a
tesla autopilot system behind a trailer
full of traffic lights
that is getting horribly horribly
confused because it's like i can see
traffic lights look where's the traffic
lights and you know they never
anticipated this like there might be
traffic lights in front of the car which
are on their way to somewhere so we have
to you know be prepared for these things
to crop up i probably wouldn't have
thought of that if i was working on that
system you know but eventually someone
out there in the real world is going to
come back with a scenario maybe a
scenario that they found themselves in
that happened to them and they're going
to be like hey i was running your tesla
and there was a truck full of traffic
lights in front of me sometimes though
users take the system we built and they
misuse it in the most delightful
ingenious ways because people are really
smart at coming up with ways of using
technology that the people who built the
technology did not anticipate a friend
of mine used to work for a company who
made uh electron microscopes you know
really really kind of high-end
very paranoid about industrial espionage
to the point that even though they had
field service engineers all over the
world repairing these devices they had a
corporate firewall that didn't let you
email attachments you couldn't send
attachments zip files xes dlls couldn't
send anything in or out of the building
on pain of being fired you will not
violate the corporate policy you will
not send attachments so you know what
they did
set up a hotmail box and everyone had
the password and if you needed something
you'd ring your mate back at head office
and go hey i need this file and they
would attach it to an email in the
drafts folder and you would sign in and
download it and then you'd delete it
email never never got sent
nobody broke any rules but they had a
job to do you know they had to work
around this restriction which made it
difficult and they're like well these
are the rules and this is the problem
and this is the available technology
let's see if we can figure out a way of
making that work now sometimes you know
you get weird little defects in software
which actually turn out to be really
significant
does anyone know what this thing is
this is a lorenz attractor um it's a
it's a mathematical projection of a
chaotic system but all you need to know
about it for this talk is that it's a
maths thing that looks pretty and is
actually very cool and it was discovered
by this guys this is edward lorenz and
uh in 1961 he was working on a computer
system called the royal mcb lgp 30. um
does any of you know a thing called the
story of mel a real programmer that kind
of float around the internet for a while
mel k also programmed one of these
things this was a computer with 120
kilohertz cpu it had drum memory it
weighed 360 kilograms
and lorenz was a meteorologist he was
using this thing to simulate weather he
had built this a little weather
simulation system and he would put in a
bunch of data for his his simulated
weather system he'd set the computer
running and it would print
graphs showing temperature or rainfall
some statistic that he was simulating
and one day he's halfway through running
a simulation something goes wrong
there's a bug in his program and he
thinks okay well that's okay i can type
the data off the printout and i can run
the simulation again and what he noticed
was the second time he ran the
simulation
this happened
it didn't run the same it's like this is
what's going on it's the same computer
same program same inputs same outputs
and he had a closer look at it and he
realized
after no small amount of head scratching
that the printout was truncated to three
significant figures but the computer's
memory
was accurate to six figures
and that those that point zero zero zero
something of these numbers was enough to
produce a completely different output
and this was the kind of the first
moment that he says by his own admission
he's like that's the day i realized we'd
never be able to forecast the weather
like computer weather forecasting was
basically doomed because even this
really simplified simulation but that
mistake you know that failure in that
system actually so the seeds for an
entirely new branch of science because
chaos theory emerged from that computer
bug
and the idea of studying systems which
are so dependent on their inputs that if
you tweak it by like 1 1 000 you will
get radically different output within a
very very short space of time now that i
think is a lovely example of hey the
computer went wrong and actually we
discovered a whole new branch of science
as a result of embracing that failure
you know
now weather forecasting
i'm sure you've all done the thing where
you you lie on your back in a field on a
sunny day and you you look at patterns
going sort of through the sky and you
recognize them and we have come up with
computer systems that can simulate and
mimic the pattern recognition that
exists in the human brain uh we take a
whole stack of labeled photographs cats
and dogs and we feed them through
something called a convolutional neural
network and eventually we get something
out the other end which is a computer
that can tell the difference between
say i don't know a dog and a muffin
which doesn't sound difficult
but the beautiful thing about this you
know this was was serious technology the
people who created this are computer
vision researchers wanting to be able to
do uh you know all sorts of important
applications autonomous vehicles you
know analysis of crowds facial
recognition
for security airports these kinds of
things
but then a bunch of people were like
this is interesting you've built a thing
that can detect dogs
now
i turned up yesterday i quite like dogs
i'm like oh we're gonna be here for the
next couple of days i wonder if there's
any dogs in this building so i took
their their dog detector their neural
network and i ran it across this
photograph i took and uh it said you
know we're going to uh count the number
of dogs that are visible in this picture
and what we've determined is
there are no dogs here
but that's the point where the users get
ingenious and we're like no no turn
around turn the dog detector into a dog
amplifier run it on this picture and
let's crank up the power
now the people who build it are like
you're not supposed to do that that's
not what we created this technology for
but we're like no no no come on
let's crank up the power level two
level three
level four
and i love this kind of serendipity you
know this is deep dreaming it's a it's
an artistic technique that would never
exist if we didn't one invent some
really really smart computer systems and
then to wire them in backwards because
we're awkward and we're difficult and we
we like breaking the rules
and uh i want to wrap up today by
telling you about uh one of my favorite
examples ever of people using technology
in a way that
they probably weren't supposed to
i grew up in africa i was born in kenya
i spent my childhood in zimbabwe when i
was a kid family holidays you'd get in
the back of the car and you'd drive
you'd drive a long long way uh yeah a
lot of it on dirt roads without any kind
of tarmac and every once in a while
you'd see in the distance that'd be like
a little red hot or something and it was
always red red and white and it was
hand-painted coca-cola and that's where
you could uh you could stop and get cold
drinks and stuff
and within the last kind of 20 years
you could go to places in africa now
that look exactly like that they are
identical except the little red and
white shack in the distance under the
tree it's still red and white but it's
not coca-cola anymore it's vodacom
because cellular networking technology
has revolutionized africa it's uh if any
of you saw uh richard campbell yesterday
talking about azure with leapfrog
technologies and uh charles sawalo
yesterday was talking about moving me
back and emerging opportunities in
africa
africa kind of never got a telephone
network because
it's a vast continent you'd need
hundreds of thousands of kilometers of
cable to get to a village where there
are 200 people who have no money
now you add into that there is very
little opportunity there for private
sector investment just because you're
not gonna get that money back when you
factor in uh you know lack of access to
resources corruption is a factor when it
comes to government-funded projects um
you know bureaucracy difficulties in
getting things to happen africa
basically went from having nothing to
having cell phones because the bid in
the middle was prohibitively expensive
and eventually the technology came in
moving the other way but something else
happened around the same time
this is nairobi it's the capital city of
kenya
if you went to nairobi around the year
2000 like you know just after the whole
millennium bug thing kicked off um
downtown nairobi is a modern city it's
got investment banks five-star hotels
restaurants there's even a couple of you
know dot-com internet startups running
around there but you could travel
not very far a couple of hours outside
the city and meet people who had never
seen a computer people who had never
made a telephone call you know
this was the infrastructure challenge so
when they started rolling out cellular
network communication technology
it solves the problem of the wiring
because you don't need the wires but
what it doesn't solve is the problem of
you have a country where nearly 80
percent of people are what's called
unbanked they don't have bank accounts
so all of the mobile phones that were
rolled out in this kind of first launch
they were all pay as you go
and
most people didn't have enough money to
buy a phone
but there would be someone in your town
or your village who did and so they
became almost like a public utility
there would be somebody there who had a
phone that you could go and use if you
needed to make phone calls now
one of the big economic challenges in uh
places like kenya was there was no way
of transferring money people didn't have
bank accounts so you would you know go
and get a job in the city and you'd get
paid and then you'd have money and you
want to send that money home to your
family out in the countryside
and you have a couple of choices one you
can take four days off work to make the
round trip yourself and give it to them
in person you can't do that every week
and you know they can't really afford to
go without any money for six months or
you put the money in an envelope and you
give it to a bus driver who's going in
the right direction and you kind of
cross your fingers that eighty percent
of the money will probably make it to
the other end within a couple of years
this is how it worked this is the the
realities of of managing that kind of
infrastructure
and then somebody worked out
that you could take your earnings from
your job and you could go into a safari
com office in downtown nairobi and you
could buy a 250 shilling top-up card
because the top-up card doesn't matter
what matters is the serial number
and then you phone the person in your
family's village who has the nokia and
you're like i got 250 shillings of top
up for you and they say all right give
me the serial number they top their
phone up so you've just transferred
value next time your mom goes into the
store shopkeepers like hey i have 200
shillings from your son and 50 to for
themselves as you know a small handling
fee
this was phase one they had a way if you
had someone on the other end who you
kind of trusted you could transfer air
time by reading out the number they
could top up their phone with that they
would then charge people to come into
the shop and make calls so you had a
sort of
slightly informal way of transferring
money but then
they rolled out the ability to send
currency using top-ups uh not to send
currency to send a airtime using sms
messages they built in the facility that
if you had a bunch of money on your
phone you could send someone a text
message and say like here's 100 minutes
or here's 50 shillings worth of airtime
credit to friends and family
and people figured out very very quickly
that okay one list is good you can send
money and then the person on the other
end can go in and they can turn it back
into cash they keep the top up and they
give the cash to your family your mother
whatever
but as people started to trust the
system they're like well maybe we don't
need to cash out
maybe we can just send each other air
time we can send each other minutes as a
way of paying for things and this was
the system that kind of got established
people could uh you know someone would
start out they'd earn money they'd buy a
top-up card they'd put credit on their
phone they'd go to the market they'd buy
a sack of flour they'd pay with a text
message the person who got the flower
would take their kid to the doctor pay
with a text message and the doctor would
need a new tire for the bicycle
they'd go to the bike shop they'd pay
with a text message the airtime just
kept circulating now
this is the point where
i think a lot of companies would have
gone
this isn't working
like no one's making phone calls what
was the point in putting in this mobile
phone network all they're doing is
texting each other at time they're never
actually spending it you know they're
not actually using the credit to make
calls how are we going to make money out
of this system
but what vodafone and safaricom did is
they thought they're actually on to
something here you know this is a
massive opportunity and in
2007 i think it was they launched a
system called pesa
uh for mobile and pacer is the swahili
word meaning money and pesa was a
completely bankless cashless
digital currency system and pacer is
still trying to shut this down in kenya
right now would be like telling everyone
in europe they're not allowed to use
mastercard anymore it has become that
established it is the de facto payment
solution now this is not phone banking
there is no bank account behind this
your mobile phone is your digital wallet
and it's not crypto there is no
blockchain or distributed ledger
involved
people trust the phone company that's
how this thing works and the phone call
and pacer you know the the company set
up by the phone company is like
initially this was just we will let you
transfer money backwards and forwards
then they're like we can have a savings
account we'll pay you interest on this
we will uh start lending money we'll do
small business startup loans and pesa
it became a route out of poverty for
something like 250 000 people
and all of that because the users didn't
use it properly
they looked at that piece of tech and
they went
uh
they want us to make calls with this no
no
i've got a much better idea and so
what i just you know that's the sort of
thought i want to leave you with is when
you
put technology out into the world
anticipate that it is going to go wrong
don't ever be the person who's like well
it's not a bug in our software because
maybe your software is a perfect part of
a flawed system maybe your software
doesn't has bugs but it's doing the
wrong thing because you didn't
anticipate that you were going to be
behind a trailer full of traffic lights
going down the freeway you know maybe
your email system that you built it
worked perfectly but the users are
getting more value out of it by swapping
attachments using the drafts folder
always be willing to
listen to what people are actually doing
with your stuff if they say it doesn't
work listen to them maybe there's a
problem maybe there's an opportunity
maybe there is something in here that
you didn't even think about which could
unlock a completely new kind of science
or a new kind of commerce or any of
these kinds of things because no matter
how hard we try to ship software which
is tested and scalable and has no
defects failure is always an option
thank you very much
a few minutes for questions but i'm
aware we didn't get a break before this
session so come and find me if you have
questions or go and get coffee i don't
mind
thank you